you blew it
super hard
complete buffoonery I'm not being
melodramatic when I say that people from
Eagleton are snobby and evil and they
look down on Pawnee and they would most
likely exterminate everyone who isn't
from Eagleton if they weren't so busy
being obsessed with themselves
oh God that was close
sometimes when I rant about Eagleton I
forget to breathe and I pass out here's
a text for your speech I added a few
more jokes slamming Eagleton at the end
it's the sexiest thing you've ever said
to me so glad you're on my team are you
sure you want to attack them at this
press conference it's a friendly wager
on a high school basketball game I'm
losing the recall election Ben slamming
Eagleton is the easiest way to score
some points look am I proud of it yes
because Eagleton sucks but is it the
classiest move yes because Eagleton
sucks would I do it again yes because
Eagleton sucks this year we get to host
the Pawnee Eagleton tip-off classic that
awful human being is Ingrid DeForest
she's a city councilor from Eagleton she
thinks she's so great because she won
the Miss India at a beauty pageant last
year while she was in office
and Pregnant
as always we would like to make a
friendly wager with Eagleton if you beat
us this year we will give you a basket
of apples from our Pawnee Orchard
pesticide yuck oh no these are pesticide
free I ate one of these for breakfast
this morning and I found a worm in it so
I bet somebody feels pretty stupid right
now well Leslie I think we had similar
ideas if you win Eagleton will give you
this basket of oranges
of course it's silly to compare apples
and oranges but what the heck these are
made of Swarovski Crystal and they're
worth seven hundred thousand dollars
Leslie uh you're down 15 points in the
latest Poll for the recall election what
can you do to make up the deficit I'll
tell you what I do if I was an
eagletonian I'd pop a Xanax and ask my
butler to help me out
saying that egotonians are out of touch
but when you tell them it's time to
change their oil they ask extra virgin
or white truffle
thanks guys I'll see you at the game
unless of course you're an evil Tony and
then you'll be too busy polishing your
monocle at the caviar store nope out
[Applause]
he designed this place what a dump Ben
Leslie hi hi rest in St James thank you
so much for coming oh thank you well
what do you think of our newest Park
in a word underwhelming and a little
inconvenient there's no trash cans
anywhere what am I supposed to do with
my garbage just throw it on the ground
oh hey
thank you for the trash Mr St James I
have to say this park is incredible
thank you its official name is Five Mile
grounds but we like to call it wide
Smiles abound because of all the smiles
that occur it's so boring well come on
I'll take you guys a little tour great
he seems super cool and he seems cool
just you wait
well they always whine and dine you
first but the fact of the matter is
egotonians are without exception snobby
condescending jerks
honey side of our border with Eagleton
and this is the Eagleton side
they put up a fence
who
no what's that there's a small park on
the line between Queen Pawnee and
Eagleton and last night Eagleton put up
a fence around their side to keep us
disgusting Pony hobos off their precious
land there's even a security guard you
gotta show Eagleton ID to get in
Eagleton is a bunch of Rich snobs and
that's coming from someone who has a
Mercedes with the Hardy Carmen logic 7
surround sound system who builds a fence
to keep kids out of a playground three
words Lindsay Carlisle Shea
who is the Eagleton side really that
much better than the Pawnee side to be
fair yeah our side is this Scrappy piece
of land where kids go to smash
fluorescent light tubes
but it has a lot of heart that's what
people always say when something sucks
Leslie's put together a presentation for
financial recovery great you may find it
very informative let's get started with
our first slide
well well well
you blew it
super hard
complete buffoonery it's hilarious and
you deserve it hey do you think you
might want to take it easy on that oh
like they took it easy on us when they
stole all our money and seceded from our
towns 200 years ago cool it fine ask
your bed do you have a plan that will
help us or not we have borrowed
absolutely everything we can from the
state and really
Pawnee is our only hope we do have a
plan we are willing to provide a bridge
loan
for fifty thousand dollars 25 interest
compounded monthly and you need to
release a statement that says that
Pawnee rules in Eagleton drools well now
you're just being nasty I understand
that our towns have a complicated
history but
we have a saying in Eagleton
you don't kick a dressage horse after a
failed party do whatever Blondie your
butler made your bed now you gotta lie
in it and if you walk out that door none
of us here and I repeat none of us will
ever help you again oh my God they have
Michael Buble on retainer
you might have a fancy car and a
mahogany purse or whatever rich people
have but I remember something that
you're trying to forget you're a Pawnee
girl no Leslie I'm not well then why do
you come here at dinner time and get
takeout from the legendary JJ's Diner
not for me
these waffles make great dog laxatives
don't you dare
feed that waffle to that dog to get it
to poop
you need to make there you go Leslie how
dare you
guys
[Applause]
May 1817 a scrappy group of Frontiers
men and women arrive at A Hard Scrabble
chunk of land and call it Pawnee Indiana
we owe them a debt of gratitude
June 1817 the richest among them take
all of their money from the bank and
then flee up the hill like cowards to
form Eagleton
recognize any of your ancestors among
the meanies actually like most people
from the area I have ancestors on both
sides that's why I think this rivalry is
just a little silly and self-defeating
yeah you may not know this but Leslie
was actually born in Eagleton do not
blame me for the sins of my mother
look Ms note
I'm really trying here but I just don't
know if our working together is such a
great idea we're running away so soon
typical you know say what you want about
pawnians but we never give up we have a
mural called the many surrenders of
Pawnee look who's been to me now okay
can I speak to you privately for a
minute Mr St James this has been a
strange day uh but we wouldn't want to
leave you with the wrong impression of
Pawnee have you guys seen Hitler
anyway we would love to have you design
the park and in the spirit of
reconciliation Leslie would like to
apologize I may have allowed my
prejudices my totally legitimate
prejudices against Eagleton affect my
feelings towards your involvement in
this project and so therefore I would
like to say that I'm
I'm
I'm Leslie nope
no
that's not what I was saying okay
I'm
my mouth is kind of dry
um
and I'll just dry this is Canada Dry
drink Canada Dry if your mouth is dry
that's nothing what I want to say is I'm
sorry I'm sorry
you're a human being you can just just
say I'm sorry oh my God I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry that I'm sorry
very sorry
said I was rude so you were technically
born in Eagleton who cares I care the
people of Pawnee care I wrote on the
cover of my book that I was born in
Pawnee I went on Pawnee today and I
called Joan a liar
I'm a liar I'm worse than a liar I'm an
angletonian